make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and the eternals trailer just
dropped so in this video i'm going to
make you guys an expert on icarus of the
eternals who's really the most powerful
of the entire race and he's also
immortal so icarus first appeared in
marvel comics with eternals vol 1 issue
number one in july of 1976 and he was
created by jack kirby now if you guys
are familiar
with the video that we did on the
eternals explained and if you're not
i'll have a link to that video down in
the description which will really give
you more of the origin
just because of the fact that the entire
race doesn't play a huge role with
regards to like the greater marvel
comics landscape it's largely individual
members right athena
cersei icarus uh dane whitman uh it's
really more of these individual
characters who play a role hence the
reason why we're also breaking down the
characters
individually uh but the idea behind this
in our in our kind of origin discussion
there is we talked about how jack kirby
created the eternals coming out of his
fourth world
kind of creation over at dc comics the
issue was that after he created darkseid
the forever people
steppenwolf all that kind of stuff dc
wouldn't let him do what he wanted to do
with it and so ultimately he left and
then went back to marvel and so when he
created the eternals he was kind of
given license to just sort of do
whatever it is that he wanted to do
because it was jack kirby at that point
in time it was kind of like
jack kirby let him do what he wants and
so the funny thing about icarus is that
his birth kind of coincides
with the sinking of of lumeria and
atlantis by the celestials but then we
also didn't have a whole lot of his
backstory that was going on there right
so what we know here
is that at some point in the past if you
guys are familiar with the celestials
that the celestials showed up on earth
they modified the genes of early man
and some of those individuals went on to
become the eternals where they could
manipulate
cosmic energies when the celestials came
back a second time to study their
experiments they found two things that
happened
the first is that the eternals which had
been tasked with safeguarding humanity
had basically abandoned their role the
second thing that happened is that one
of the other groups the celestials
created called the deviants who are
basically like trolls monsters that kind
of a thing had essentially enslaved
humanity and so the results of this is
that the deviants attacked the
celestials
the celestials sunk the kingdom of
atlantis and then they turned on the
eternals and then warned them should
they vacate their role again that
they'll destroy the eternals they'll
wipe the earth clean and they'll start
all over again and so that's why the
eternals played more of a hands-on role
when it came to humanity it was around
this time
that icarus as we know him was basically
born the biggest problem with this is
we didn't really know much about his
backstory in fact we still kind of don't
this wasn't really given to us on any
measurable level until we got to a
couple different stories
the first of these was thor annual
number seven by roy thomas in 1978 and
the second one was eternals volume 2
issue number 5 by peter b gillis in
1986. now thor annual number seven we'll
talk about here in a minute because i
think that really has more to do with
the greater
eternals role than anything else with
eternal volume 2 issue number 5 what you
got here was this story whereby
when icarus had challenged a member of
the eternals of the olympian eternals
with regards to essentially treason
against the eternals race that you got
this kind of backstory here and what you
ended up learning is that the name
icarus actually follows and was really
the reason
why the greek mythological story of
icarus exists in marvel comics so if you
guys aren't familiar with the greek
mythological story what it basically
says
is that there was a kid named icarus and
ultimately he was given a set of wax
wings by his father but he was warned
not to fly too close to the sun
or the wings would melt and so what
ended up happening is he ignored his
father's warnings and he flew too close
to the sun
and what happened is exactly what his
father said would happen the wings
melted and then he fell into the ocean
and he drowned
and so the story of icarus here and for
the sake of this little tidbit here
we'll say icarus senior
and icarus jr will say that icarus
senior at some point in ancient greece
had actually gotten together with a
woman at the time
and then fathered a son who became
icarus jr the biggest issue with this
is that with the eternals and the
deviants always being at war with
each other and always coming into
conflict due to the fact that the
deviants are always trying to find a way
back to the surface and to kind of
retake their role as being a dominant
race so essentially enslaving humanity
and then also trying to destroy the
eternals at the same time this would
basically lead icarus senior to leaving
his home
for large periods of time and then kind
of traveling around the various
locations around earth
and facing off against the deviants now
it wasn't as though icarus senior did
this because he just didn't want to have
a family he found them to be an issue
if anything and one of the things that
was kind of established here by peter b
gillis is that it was just the result of
him being alive for so long that in this
lifespan that he's lived the idea of him
having a son
and watching his son grow to you know
maybe 80 years old assuming that he
would age at the same rate as immortal
would happen
in the blink of an eye right so for him
being gone for years at a time
would be like us being gone for like an
hour or two right it just it's not that
lengthy of a period of time at least as
far as as he was concerned
and so because of the the exploits and
the endeavors he was in he would leave
his home his wife and his son at home
for years at a time and so ultimately
his son actually
ended up kind of taking this this
ability that he had to fly which was
gifted to him by his father
and then took off and actually ended up
in space passed out from the lack of
oxygen and then fell into the ocean and
drowned and that was exceedingly
important because it was one of the
first times that we really got a
meaningful backstory for icarus senior
in the sense that we learned
that's why he called himself icarus
because prior to that point he had a
name we never found out what it was but
he had a name and so when his son died
his idea here was that if he takes the
name of his son then his son will
effectively live on forever and so when
you get into thor annual issue number
seven again this one was really more
important with regards to the larger
uh eternals mythos because it
established an exceedingly important
thing
one of the things this kind of
established and then built on a little
bit is that in the days of earth when
you had you know humanity kind of
running around doing its own thing
you also had olympians so you had zeus
you had hera you had uh apollo and all
those guys you had odin you had
thor and so on and so forth and so while
the eternals largely resided on earth
and didn't really delve into like other
dimensions although some of them did
kind of defect and then go out into
space
the eternals themselves were well aware
of the olympians and they were well
aware of thor and odin and all those
guys they knew about them all because
they'd just been around for so long
if anything they found the olympians a
little intriguing they found the idea of
like hercules fighting among the mortals
like an olympian god effectively
leaving his uh leaving what would be his
rightful place and then just kind of
existing among the mortals to be
something kind of fascinating but they
also saw this as a potential situation
but they also saw this as a possible
situation where it could
impede with the experiment of the
celestials and that's one of the more
important things that i want to want to
establish here before we kind of
continue on with this history of icarus
is that the eternals are nothing if not
devoted to ensuring that the experiment
of the celestials does not go awry
because quite literally their lives
depend on it if something happens and
the the celestial experiment goes awry
something goes wrong humanity's
destroyed or whatever it is then like
the celestials would all be wiped out
right so it's in their best interest to
make sure
that things go smoothly and so seeing
the possibility of somebody like
hercules or
or odin or thor or zeus or hera or any
of those various gods that exist out
there and those are only part of the sky
fathers right you've got like eastern
european gods and things like that
seeing them involved in the affairs of
mortal man intrigued the eternals now
all that came to a head with a celestial
third host when they showed up and they
realized that thor and odin and all
those guys were messing around in the
affairs of mortal men so they basically
said if you guys keep on doing it we're
gonna wipe you guys out too right i mean
they were very much like
leave our experiment alone right they
were very much you know leave these guys
alone let humanity progress of its own
accord which was kind of marvel's
explanation for why it is that odin and
those guys were at one point
kind of seen all over the place by
humanity and then one day they just
stopped right it just it just ended all
of a sudden uh but nonetheless kind of
kind of moving forward here with regards
to the the history of icarus
icarus just kind of gravitated you know
from one place to the next and a few
things happened here and there honestly
we don't really know a whole lot about
its history prior to the modern era but
then you get to peter b gilles's run
and this is really kind of like the idea
of the fourth celestial host now the way
this worked is that because the
celestials had tasked the eternals with
essentially safeguarding humanity the
eternal secondary job was to monitor
earth until such a point where enough
superheroes emerged to where the
eternals it was really worth their time
to actually
grab the celestials bring them to earth
and have them see the fruition of their
experiment and so the idea behind the
eternals was to kind of safeguard this
beacon that existed in peru where they
would basically travel to that location
activated and then it was more or less
sending out a message to the celestials
hey
your experiment might be ready come take
a look and let us know what you think
whether or not you want to save the
world or you want to eliminate the world
right wipe it clean and then start all
over again hence the role
of ereshim the judge of the of the
celestials right to determine whether or
not a world is worth continuing to exist
or wiping it clean
and so what ended up happening here is
you actually saw icarus coming into
contact with two people the first was dr
daniel damien and the second one was his
daughter
margot and so what ended up happening
here is their curiosity
about the eternals the various myths and
legends and stories and things like that
because
up to that point in time for the average
person out there the eternals were
largely believed to have been gods they
were considered mythical
right but like old stories that depicted
these kind of angelic beings who existed
out there right the perfect looking
human with perfect skin and things like
that that was those were stories
involving the eternals likewise stories
are dealt with like monsters and trolls
ascending from underground
that dealt with the deviants but it drew
the attention of of dr damian and his
daughter margot and so ultimately icarus
encountered the two of them and he ended
up facing off against a couple of
deviants and then ultimately activated
the beacon in order to
bring the celestials onto earth for the
fourth host now this kind of coincided
with
sort of a secondary kind of tying into
or at least bookending to a previous
story would have basically dealt with
the idea of the celestials arriving on
earth and then initially judging against
it and deciding that earth needed to be
cleansed and started over again but you
ended up getting a handful of
individuals with incredible powers who
are presented to the uh to the
celestials and the celestials in turn
deemed the earth worthy and said okay
fine our experiment is progressing the
way that it's supposed to now the full
totality of the celestial's experiment
would come to fruition and franklin
richards the son of reed richards the
leader of the fantastic four hence the
reason why i really hope they bring him
in
because he's basically a kid who's on
par with galactus and power he's more
than enough to handle a celestial
franklin richards in his adult form
is god here but nonetheless you kind of
saw these moments this is one of the big
issues that you had with the eternals
you had these things where icarus and
even the rest of the eternals athena
people like that uh
ajax and then ajax right they're two
separate people you would see them just
kind of like travel around and do a few
things here and there but it was largely
background stuff
but there was a huge moment that came to
fruition in avengers issues 246-248 now
these stories were written by roger
stern back in 1984 and there was an
interview he did with tomorrow's
publishing where he basically
established this idea that if you were
reading mobile comics at the time
icarus despite the the limited
appearances of the eternals in marvel
icarus was far and away the most popular
right just because of the fact that you
saw him among earth superheroes more
than anybody else
even if it was only ever like momentary
appearances and different things like
that this was especially important when
you got into iron man issue number 179
and iron man
annual issue number six which actually
saw the two of them crossing over it saw
icarus and the eternals
encountering iron man and then facing
off against crowe who was basically
uh the general of the deviant forces so
that kind of exposure especially with
icarus is really what kind of elevated
its character and we've talked about
that in the past that was kind of like
standard fare for marvel comics it's why
like the fantastic four can kind of
consider to be like the first family
because they were the most popular team
that marvel had and so if marvel wanted
to introduce new characters right black
panther they wanted to beef up the
popularity of the x-men which didn't
work
if they wanted to you know kind of
increase the stature or or at least
give a little more exposure to somebody
like spider-man who really didn't need
it you would see them cross over with
the fantastic four
or something along those lines but the
idea by uh roger stern was that for the
most part a lot of the eternals that
existed out there right fina ajax
all those characters didn't really seem
to have a significant role because you
didn't really see them all that often
and so the idea was that during the
storyline of the fourth celestial host
that roger stern just kind of wanted to
remove them from the equation but he
didn't want to kill them off because he
wanted the possibility of being able to
bring them back and and the reason why
this matters is because at this point in
time
superman over at dc comics had not died
and come back to life the significance
behind that is
when superman died and came back it was
basically all bets were off or you could
kill and bring anybody back at any point
in time and so at this point in in comic
books as a whole
marvel dc pretty much anybody else death
was still kind of a definitive thing and
so if you killed a character off
it was largely that they just stayed
dead but they just never came back and
so what you ended up getting was
a handful of really most of the most of
the eternals basically leaving earth but
they formed something or used something
called the unimod
now the unimine is both a source of
power as well as a deciding force when
it comes to the eternals themselves and
the way this works is you usually need
about seven although looking at the
trailer of the mcu when you have the
three eternals who are kind of hovered
together and there's the energy bond
between the three of them that looks
like they're forming the unimine so it
looks like you might only need like
three or it could just
be that that's just the formation of the
unimine and the other four end up
joining suit alongside them and then
ultimately make a call but the idea
behind the unimine is to kind of bring
the
the sort of energies of the eternals
together and then make definitive
statements right make definitive
decisions and this happens in a couple
different ways the first
is that it can be with regards to
whether or not they go to war it could
be with whether or not they decide to
summon the celestials for this
particular situation in avengers 2 46
through 248
it was icarus replacing fina as the
prime eternal and what that means is he
is in effect
the leader of the eternals themselves
now the role's not really
it's not really a symbolic role it's a
role that's really reserved much in the
way that like odin is the all father
it's not enough to ceremoniously be
brought into this role you also have to
be able to maintain
it so you have to prove that like you're
the strongest of the eternals you're the
most capable the most
honorable of the eternals and so on and
so forth right so there's a lot of
factors that go into it and so what
ended up happening is icarus went
forward as essentially the kind of
safeguard of humanity where he was
basically the eternal or one of the few
eternals that resided on earth and then
would actually have
more of a hand and the various goings on
on earth and that was the other part of
what roger stern
really decreed here is that if the
eternals were going to exist in marvel
comics they couldn't just be this group
that was just kind of sheltered away
they had to have more of a significant
role in the goings-on of marvel comics
in terms of how it was published
from this story going forward the
eternals and especially
icarus would have far more of a
prominent role in marvel comics
and so running from silver surfer annual
number one in 1988 all the way up to
eternals volume
3 in 2006 while i wouldn't say that
icarus had the most prominent role in
marvel comics and they kind of i would
guess they didn't necessarily go
directly with the idea that roger stern
was putting forward
you did see him have a few involved or a
little bit of involvement with various
characters who existed out there
for example in silver surfer annual
number one you actually saw icarus and
the eternals or at least the remaining
eternals facing off against the high
evolutionary those of you guys who don't
know what that is the high evolutionary
is basically a guy who ended up uh
boosting up his own evolution he kind of
deals with like genetic modifications
different things like that
and basically increases uh his
capabilities to the point where he
almost reached godhood and the idea was
to basically take a sample of the of the
blood
and dna of the eternals to kind of
figure out how to duplicate more of them
he's had really significant stories in
marvel comics i'm not trying to kind of
write him off as an irrelevant character
the high evolutionary is very important
in marvel and he's had some major
stories up but nonetheless
in all honesty the various escapades of
icarus and really the eternals really
kind of took a backseat right so roger
stern's you know
decree was more or less kind of ignored
by marvel comics by the time you got
into the mid to late 2000s marvel was
drastically different from the way that
it was back in like the 1970s 1980s and
especially the 1990s marvel had just
kind of come out of the dark rain era
and so what you had was something called
the heroic age and the idea behind this
heroic age was essentially this idea
that the various heroes who had
previously stepped down and gone
underground
following norman osborne the green uh
green goblin becoming director of shield
had since returned
following the really the events of siege
on asgard and the conclusion of dark
rain and the fact that norman osborne
had basically been arrested after his
misdeeds were kind of made public and
then heroes went back to
to being traditional heroes right it
kind of concluded this 10-year epic that
marvel had to kind of reduce the
population of superheroes who were out
there
and to rework various characters the
eternals were among these now a story
that i do want to point out here is one
that came
in eternals volume four this story was
originally written by charles noff and
it's probably one of the most
significant stories they're ever written
by the eternals and in fact it actually
took place back in 2009 and what you
ended up finding out here was
this great big huge kind of adjustment
to the eternals mythos in the sense of
answering the question
where do the eternals go when they die
why'd you like go to the realm of
mistress death where like every regular
mortal goes except for those who believe
in asgard then they end up going to the
realm of hella or something like that
where do these guys go when they die
what happens to the celestials different
things like that and these were in all
honesty a lot of questions that even
just me as a comic book reader never
really occurred to me to ask and that's
why the story was so fascinating but it
also kind of established the eternals
and the deviants as this almost sort of
standard of
absolute right and absolute evil and it
was really charles knopf just kind of
hearkening back to the original jack
kirby intention which was to establish
the eternals as absolute good and to
establish the deviance as absolute evil
it didn't necessarily work out in the
most pure sense as far as jack kirby
wrote it especially when he got to the
idea of the eternals is kind of
abandoning the role that was established
for them by the celestials but i would
really say eternal vol 4 is more of a
story that focuses on the dreaming
celestial than anybody else but the
important thing here is we were kind of
given this character called the fulcrum
and the way this works is that after 19
cycles or seemingly uh 19 generations or
however long
a period of a cycle is i don't think
it's really established in marvel that
these celestials will basically arrive
on any given planet where they conducted
their experiment and they will
ultimately destroy it not necessarily
because the experiment was a failure but
because that's just the end result right
it's just a test it's like when you
conduct an experiment when you're done
you toss the experiment right you
dispose of it adequately but the way
this kind of
of litmus test worked is that if the
energy signature of the beings on that
world
were more in tune with the eternals
meaning they were largely heroes they
performed good deeds then the energy of
that of that world would go to the
celestials however if a world was more
in tune with the deviants meaning the
world was more evil it was more twisted
they engaged in more
i guess evil acts for lack of a better
word that energy would basically go to
the horde and so it was kind of a
sort of checks and balance right almost
a kind of weight system
on how you determine the morality of a
particular world now a lot of the story
kind of went into the dreaming celestial
basically achieving
sentience and abandoning the idea that
it just does what it's told
and achieving kind of like a higher
state of enlightenment and then
basically
joining in with the fulcrum the fulcrum
itself even then is highly ambiguous
right we don't know much about it it's
just people kind of consider it to be
like a a fraction of the one below all
and just kind of chalk it up to that we
don't really have any definitive answers
but one of the more important roles that
actually came with the
with the eternals themselves and it
really came out of uh really came with
the incredible hulk vol 2 issue number
49
written in 2012 which was a desire by
marvel and really jeff loeb
to kind of bring the eternals more into
the to the mainline marvel comics was
when you had red hulk
face off against icarus now a lot of
this was because of the fact that at the
time the eternals were largely debating
whether or not they should conquer the
earth or whether or not they should just
abandon the planet by that point the
fourth celestial host had already come
and gone
and so there was no real reason to
believe that celestials would return
anymore right the
stories of the eternals the prophecy of
the celestials the idea that they would
come
and judge the earth one final time that
was that was over and done with and so
there wasn't really going to be any
concern about the celestials coming back
and being mad that the eternals had
basically left earth and so what you had
here was this kind of argument presented
among some of the eternals which was
we should look at the the overall
superhero landscape and really determine
whether or not it's worth saving and so
the litmus test for this
was a version of the incredible hulk now
the reason why the red hulk was used
here was because at the time
bruce banner in the as the incredible
hulk was basically kind of locked
underground so he was really kind of
removed from the picture and it was a
way for molly to kind of move him out of
the way
take all the emphasis off the incredible
hulk and put everybody's eyes on the red
hulk which was kind of this big mystery
of who the red hulk was
ultimately we learned it was thunderbolt
ross but nonetheless the fact that you
got to see icarus fighting off against a
version of the hulk even if not
the prime incredible hulk was still
pretty cool and it was enough to where
it kind of pushed the the eternals into
more of a public eye
now by 2015 marvel was gearing up for
secret wars right i'd say really it
started back in 2012 uh running up for
about three years when marvel was more
or less not really rebooting although it
looked like they were going to reboot
but effectively reworking their entire
landscape
and so as far as i can tell and and i
read through the
the last day's events and and really a
lot of those tie-ins quite readily i
wasn't able to really
find anything that had anything to do
with the celestials regarding like
their fate in the events leading up to
the events of secret wars if they were
killed by the beyonders or or
whatever that case happens to be so if
anybody out there is 100 certain
uh let me know right it may just be
something that i missed or just some
obscure story that just simply didn't
catch my eye at the time
but in the aftermath of secret wars we
got a traditional death
of the eternals which really came in
avengers volume 8 and this is really
kind of marvel leading into a grander
story particularly with regards to the
avengers run of jason aaron and ed
mcginnis and this really kind of hit on
this idea of jason aaron just kind of
changing the history of the celestials
and all that kind of stuff that went
into it the role of the eternals and so
on and so this kind of reality
that was given to us here is that unlike
what we had previously believed which
was that the eternals existed to
safeguard humanity
because humanity was just kind of the
result of the celestial's experiments
that instead the celestials and the
horde were constantly at war with each
other so much so that the horde had
actually
infected some of the celestials and
turned them into what were called dark
celestials now truth to tell the dark
celestials were really just
aspirants that have been infected by the
horde and those you guys don't know what
the aspens are we can talk more about
that in
a later video uh if you guys are
interested right you know we can have
more of a conversation about that or you
can check out my video on al ewing's
ultimates which actually goes pretty in
depth into like the celestial and
aspirant holy war
but nonetheless the whole point here is
that the the eternals it kind of been
revealed to them
that their role was not really to
safeguard the experiment of the
celestials but that the celestials
intended to absorb the energy of
everybody on earth in order to combat
the horde and so in reality
uh the eternals kind of came to this
realization that they were
basically prison guards like they were
just kind of keeping the sheep in check
and the sheep were bound for slaughter
what this did is it created a kind of
existential crisis
among the celestials to the degree that
like their entire existence was called
into question
and everything they were supposed to do
and so this basically drove them insane
those celestials who remained those
celestials that were that were really
kind of
existing at the time either killed each
other or committed suicide and so icarus
and along with the
really all the other celestials were
more or less destroyed in the chaos than
in suit right and so the only real
benefit that humanity saw as a result
of this kind of eternal massacre more or
less was that iron man had the ability
to form the unimined and that was about
it
now what you have going on at the moment
with the eternals is actually a relaunch
by
kieran gillen and assad ribbik which is
a really really cool looking story um i
read the first issue of it i don't
believe it's finished yet and i'm not
even really sure that the entire story
has more or less come to fruition all we
really know is that icarus has kind of
fought thanos for a moment and it's
actually kind of nuts because thanos
well i won't spoil it for you but uh but
yeah icarus basically fights thanos for
a few minutes
and then you kind of get the story sort
of continued on if anything it's really
more of like the eternals version
of what you had with regards to like you
know thor by j michael cerzinski where
like thor's traveling around and
resurrecting all the asgardians who died
during ragnarok it's more or less that
same thing except it's icarus who's
doing it because he's the prime eternal
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end you are
now caught up and an expert on the
eternals and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you